excuse me
we didn't really need to get to the main
event
ladies and gentlemen I don't know where
you were
on the evening of Wednesday the 19th of
July 2017 at 10 to 6. but funnily enough
I know exactly where I was I was in my
office in Parliament watching a
compelling speech new Maiden speech by
the newly elected member for Saffron
Walden now two weeks prior to that I'd
done my own Maiden speech 10 minutes no
notes plenty of jokes I thought I'd
nailed it well or at least survived but
can we had no intention of just
surviving she turned up with a plan and
once she got through the social niceties
that go with making a maiden speech she
settled into the rhythm of making a
compelling case for Effective Government
she cited the often quoted John bright
who was supposed to have said that the
hazard Commons is the mother of all
parliaments but what he actually said in
a speech in Birmingham in 1865 and I
throw that inks on the Proud rummy what
he actually said was that this country
was the mother of parliaments this great
country had given opportunity to a 16
year old girl newly arrived from Nigeria
to work her way up through sheer natural
ability and determination to become an
MP
now I had the opportunity over the
following five years to see at very
close quarters how she developed those
skills that had been on display in
Parliament on that Wednesday evening
Gathering ministerial experience along
the way she was in the treasury more
recently she was in the department for
leveling up with me where I was
privileged to serve with her I've seen
her become a black belt in political
combat taking on all comers from all
parties in the chamber and leaving them
visibly diminished as a result of that
encounter
foreign
to the point of being Fearless
because of the strong convictions that
she holds
but she's also funny and charming and
caring and occasionally vulnerable as
evidenced by her fear of seagulls that I
saw
for myself weirdly on the Terrace of the
House of Commons one evening
but anyway animal explains why I'm proud
to be supporting her but why should you
be supporting her well looking around
the audience you look like a politically
Savvy bunch to me so I'm imagining that
you've all read the article from the
times at the weekend and you all know
that this isn't a leadership campaign
just touting various political policies
to appeal to One Wing of the party or
another this woman with vision a woman
determined to level with the British
public and explain exactly what this
government can do a smaller government
but a more effective one and as somebody
I respect tremendously recently said
governing is hard leading is difficult
reform takes guts but imagine just how
much greater our already great country
could be
if we're a prime minister who could
deliver all three ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
all right
foreign
[Applause]
for too long politicians have been
telling us that we can have it all but
you can have your cake and eat it and
I'm too here to tell you that that isn't
true it never has been there are always
tough choices in life and in politics no
free lunches no tax cuts without limits
on government spending no stronger
defense without a Slimmer state
governing involves trade-offs and we
need to start being honest about that
unlike others I'm not going to promise
you things without a plan to deliver
them people are sick of that they're
crying out for honesty
today I want to be honest about our
economic challenge the scale of the
challenge we Face means we can't run
away from the truth inflation has made
the cost of living crisis acute but the
problems go back way further we've had a
we've had a poor decade for living
standards we have overburdened our
economy there is too much unproductive
public spending consuming taxpayers
harder and Ronnie and there are too many
well-meaning regulations slowing growth
and clogging up the arteries of the
economy too many policies like the Net
Zero Target set up with no thought to
the effects on Industries in the poorer
parts of this country
[Applause]
the consequence is simply to displace
the missions to other countries
unilateral economic disarmament
and that is why
and that is why I'm running to be leader
so
[Applause]
prime minister
tells the truth because the truth will
set us free
the problems Randy and I'm in no doubt
about the scale of the challenge any new
prime minister will have to deal with
the underlying economic problems we Face
had them exacerbated by covid and by War
but what makes the situation worse is
that the answers to our problems
conservative answers haven't been
articulated or delivered in a way
appropriate to the Modern Age we have
been in the grip of an underlying
economic social cultural and
intellectual malaise the right has lost
its confidence and courage our ability
to defend the free market as the fairest
way of helping people Prosper has been
undermined it has been undermined by a
willingness to embrace protectionism for
special interest it's been undermined by
retreating in the face of the Ben and
Jerry's tendency those who say a
business's main priority is social
justice not productivity and profit and
it's been undermined by the actions of
crony capitalists to collude with big
bureaucracy to rig the system in favor
of incumbents against entrepreneurs
excuse
the truth that limited government doing
less but better is the best way to
restore faith in government has been
forgotten as we've pounded to pressure
groups and caved in to every campaigner
with a moving message and that has made
the government agenda into a shopping
list of disconnected unworkable and
unsustainable policies the knowledge
that the nation-states our Democratic
nation-state is the best way for people
to live in harmony and enjoy Prosperity
has been overridden by the noisy demands
of those who want a delicious
delegitimize decolonize and denigrate
and if we don't stand up for our shared
institutions for free speech due process
and the rule of law then we end up with
a zero-sum game of identity politics
which only increases divisions when we
need to come together
[Applause]
free markets limited government a strong
nation-state those are the conservative
principles we need to beat back
protectionism populism and polarization
and to prepare us for the challenges
ahead to win for our country if I were
prime minister I would be driven by
these conservative principles to deliver
a fairer Freer wealthier and United
Britain
to those conservative principles and a
belief in facing facts however
uncomfortable with unflinching honesty
that will guide my approach to
government and how we put things right
so how are we going to do this
an engineer a systems thinker a problem
solver in engineering you can't overcome
resistance with rhetoric you can't get
the machine to work with promises you
need to analyze the issue deeply
untangle the mess others have made and
methodically put things right in the
debate we've been having about the
future of our party and our country
there have been lots of promises to cut
taxes and I can understand why with
economic growth faltering and the
highest tax burden in decades it is
right that we ask how we reduce taxes on
businesses families and individuals and
I am committed to reducing corporate and
personal taxes but I will not enter into
a tax bidding war over my tax cuts are
bigger than yours to make promises to
make promises that you cannot keep is a
betrayal of everything that I stand for
[Applause]
and I really want to stress that the
dividing line in this race is not tax
cuts it's judgment
[Applause]
you can only deliver lower taxes if we
stop pretending that the state continue
to do everything we are currently trying
to do
[Applause]
we need to recognize it's not just a
matter of doing the same with less we
need to focus on the essentials we need
to be straight with people the idea we
can simply say efficiency savings click
our heels three times and they will
materialize it's for the birds it is the
scale and structure of government that
drives the inefficiencies my government
will discard the priorities of Twitter
and focus on the people's priorities
when we can't when we can't deliver
passports and driving licenses on time
why are we spending Millions on people
whose jobs literally didn't exist a
decade ago like staff wellbeing
coordinators in the public sector what
about what about the well-being of the
actual public who can't go on holiday
because we can't process a piece of
paper in time
[Applause]
and spending more on government than we
have ever done and yet people
satisfaction with the quality of their
day-to-day Services is falling this is
not sustainable we can't carry on
subsidizing so many young people onto
university courses which leave them with
debts and administer job prospects we
must require schools to concentrate on
effective whole class teaching of
rigorous subjects rather than allocating
tight resources to Superfluous support
staff and peripheral activities we
should get the police to focus on
neighborhood crime not waste time and
resources worrying about her feelings
online
thank you
I've been reducing what government tries
to do we not only reduce the cost of
government we not only focus we focus
government on the people's priorities we
allow the space for individuals
employers and entrepreneurs to solve
problems and only then do we create the
opportunity to cut taxes
we can reduce the amount we spend on
International aid while still remaining
a Force for good in the world we can
ensure an efficient civil service but
let's be clear simply getting rid of
diversity and equality officers is not
going to move the dial it's not good
enough to just promise a bonfire of
bangers every single Congo leader should
be accountable and stackable by a
democratic Minister we can create proper
accountability around 100 billion pounds
in Grant which government currently
dispenses every household in the country
especially during this cost of current
cost of living crisis thinks about value
for money with every pound of the earned
wages that they spend government doesn't
do that with people's hard-earned taxes
while the priority of the 300 billion
pounds the government spends on
procurement should be value for money in
truth this is being undermined by tick
box exercises and sustainability
diversity and equality these are good
things but they need to be done properly
and we mustn't move away from the core
mission
now I recognize that this is an
ambitious agenda I'm wanting to be prime
minister when you're a 42 year old is by
definition ambitious
but I am ambitious but for our country
and for our party I chose to become a
conservative MP to serve and I chose
this country because here I could
breathe free and I could be everything
that I wanted to be I grew up in Nigeria
and I saw firsthand what happens when
politicians are in it for themselves
when they use public money as their
private piggy banks when they promise
the Earth and pollute not just the air
but the whole political atmosphere with
their failure to serve others I saw what
socialism means for Millions it's
poverty and Broken Dreams I came to
Britain determined to make my way in a
country where hard work and honest
Endeavor can take you anywhere I paid my
way through college working in
McDonald's flipping burgers cleaning
loose and I learned firsthand that
earning your own money rather than
relying on others gives you not just
more freedom but more dignity
I am so grateful to so many people who
took a chance on me and helped me
succeed but I also remember that
throughout my life there have been
people who said you can't you shouldn't
this is not for you and in politics many
people who said you're in the wrong
party you're saying the wrong things you
can't do that but I'm not the sort of
person who you can sideline silence or
cancel
[Applause]
foreign
I tell the truth I fight for change I
stand up for people and I stand up for
the causes and the country I love
some might say this is no time for
novices I think this is no time for
steady as it goes sinking into decline
it's time for change
to win the next election and deliver
conservative solutions to the challenges
of today the conservative party must
stand as the party for change I have the
conviction the courage and the clarity
of thought to deliver that change for
the people of this country thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much I have a very
enthusiastic support group
thank you
um and now on to questions and I think I
have a question from Nick from the BBC
Nick thank you um
and if there's a choice between
achieving unity in your divided party or
pursuing your convictions to what comes
first Unity is
I don't agree I don't agree with the
premise of your question Nick I think
you can do both people need to know that
what you're saying is true without that
you will never get any unity and perhaps
if we've been honest with each other
um a lot longer ago we might be more
united
um than we are now perhaps if for
instance uh we hadn't made promises to
each other even within our party about
various things that we wanted to do
which some members then didn't see
happening there would be a little bit
more trust and and then a bit more Unity
so I think you have to start from first
principles if people can't believe what
you are saying if they don't know that
you're going to do what you say you're
going to do then why should they vote
for you so conviction
um creates Unity
[Applause]
thank you
and then from GB news darling McCaffrey
what is the kind of ambition for taking
over the legal party at the next general
election may only be 80 months apart
what do you think is going to win over
those soldiers those vultures
who switched to the conservative party
in 2019. I think it's it's um my
Approach is is to focus on how we can
present ourselves as a party of
government I never start by attacking
attacking labor and we are in government
and we need to continue to demonstrate
competence but also we need to show that
we are a party that um listens that
listens to the public
um for the last few months we spent a
lot of time talking about ourselves
which I think has been really unhealthy
we need to talk about people's
priorities at the moment that's cost of
living it's education it's crime it's
the it's Health and Social care it's
those bread and butter issues I do think
that conservatives have the right
policies
um and we need to articulate them better
especially when we have difficult
decisions to make but what I would say
to people who are considering voting
labor is that almost everything that we
have done that they didn't like label
wanted us to do more of it and go faster
[Applause]
um she had come from ITV
and this this trust is a couple of
supports objectives it seems to be
significant momentum behind the two of
those both of whom have served in senior
positions within the cabinet how do you
differentiate yourself and take those
two campaigns on given that there's so
much momentum
and so I uh have a lot of respect for
Rishi sunak and Liz truss I was a junior
minister to both of them in the treasury
and inequalities but I feel that there
needs to be a genuine debate in our
party before we select the leader we
shouldn't just assume that uh it's a
continuation of what we've had before
but with different personalities so I do
think I am a differentiator because I do
think that I talk a little bit more
about what the state is doing wrong I
think we sometimes get overly defensive
um as a government and don't want to
stop doing certain things because it
looks like they are u-turns I think
sometimes we worry about changing our
minds if things aren't working I'm
prepared to actually look at many of the
activities the government is carrying
out which don't necessarily need to be
which the states in fact I should say
rather than governments which don't
necessarily need to be done I think that
is a differentiator I think that I
differentiated myself from both of them
on lots of social issues um when I was
speaking and my equalities brief and I
have something to say say that I think
the party and the public want to hear so
I'm in this to win it I'm not worried
about Rishi I'm not worried about Liz or
any of the other candidates I want you
to hear the message that I'm giving
Jonathan Riley from the Sun
readers
buying groceries that are affordable if
you became prime minister on the
September 5th what would you do in the
short term
so the cost of living crisis is the big
thing that we are dealing with and
inflation is what's driving it and
likely to make things worse so tackling
inflation that's what government um
that's what governments should be doing
we need to get it under control because
if we don't things could still get a lot
worse and I think that if we focus on
the things that governments should be
doing that only government can do we
will make things easier for people both
in the short medium and long term what
I'm not going to do is come out with
lots of micro policies about giving
people 50 pounds cash here or a rebate
there I think it's very inefficient
there is a lot of dead weight in how we
run government I have people in my
constituency telling me that they don't
need the winter fuel payments that we
give them because they can afford it why
do we not have a more sophisticated
mechanism for means testing those are
the sort of long-term things which
governments should be doing which we
haven't been doing because we're
focusing um always on the short term on
the news headlines for tomorrow so what
I'm not going to do is give headline for
tomorrow I'm talking about system change
[Applause]
and finally Katie balls from spectator
um
I say you're wrong and you don't know
[Applause]
um it is true it is true that I haven't
been in cabinet That's because nobody
put me there I think if they had if they
had um they would have seen me do
exactly what I've done with every single
job in government that I've been given
and it just so happens that every time
I've been a minister I've done two
ministerial roles I was Children and
Families Minister and also because they
forgot to appoint an apprenticeships
Minister I did that while eight months
pregnant and nobody noticed that there
was a minister missing I was in the
treasury and the qualities I've done
communities and integration local
government faith I have been in multiple
departments and I've seen so much that I
think can be can be changed but by not
being in cabinet now is actually a huge
Advantage because it means that I don't
have the baggage of so many of the
decisions that's been made people want a
fresh face then they can't have somebody
who has been in cabinet a very long time
and there is more to being in cabinet
than just sitting around a table it's
not where you've been sitting it's what
we've been doing with the um with the
responsibility that's been given to you
and that's what I show
thank you
thank you thank you everybody
[Applause]
foreign